and finally new rule don't call for me
to be fired for doing uncle Steve likes
[ __ ]
I'm not saying there aren't some
instances where people have to go but
really jeez for free speech this has
become a terrifying time in American
history
like when Canada burned down the White
House last week started with the removal
of Roseanne and ended with the President
of the United States which used to be a
real job tweeting why are they firing no
talent Samantha B for the horrible
language used on her low rating show yes
the president's right what kind of [ __ ]
whole country would this be if we just
allowed people to let fly with orrible
language this is you [ __ ] I'm
gonna bomb the [ __ ] out of up grab
another [ __ ] get that son of a [ __ ]
off the field political [ __ ] they're
ripping the [ __ ] out of the sea these
are [ __ ] you're not gonna raise that
[ __ ] price
but
but you know fat Donnie is not the only
one not the only one who demands that
everyone gets fired all the time we've
all become too comfortable with playing
to clean out your desk card so many
things about Trump fans make me think
that doesn't make America look good
that's that's not who we are but that is
also true of the joy liberals also
seemed to take in vaporizing people and
making every offense a hanging offense
yes you disappeared Roseanne and it sent
a strong message to all the other racist
Republican TV stars who suffer from
multiple personality disorders after
Roseanne was fired snowflakes on the
right and the left published full lists
of everyone they've ever been offended
by who should also be fired immediately
I was the only one who made many lists
on both sides
[Music]
to all those who thought to include me
it it's an honor just to be nominated
I'm often surprised how often liberals I
talk to think that we're winning
we who control nothing winning and I
think it's because there are so many
headlines that celebrate hallow
victories of who we fired and who we
swarmed on social media who we slammed
and blasted with our tweets Jim Carrey
bestows Scott Pruitt with a savage
nickname and latest painting Oh that'll
show him the world is healed Mila Kunis
expertly trolls Mike Pence every single
month okay Mike Pence thinks Mila Kunis
is a group of desert he doesn't know who
that is he's still going to be Mike
Pence Ice Cube destroys Donald Trump
with just one tweet really just one
because I checked and Trump is still
there maybe you're thinking of the
Environmental Protection Agency or the
individual mandate or the Paris Accords
the Iran deal or abortion rights this
country's in quite a pickle
conservatives govern without shame and
liberals shame without governing
[Music]
we have lost liberals the house the
Senate the White House the Supreme Court
Kanye
our symbolic victories are the only
victories we get now they get to cut
their own taxes rip up the safety net
and make coal a vegetable we get to
banish actors in ten years the Tea Party
went from nothing to controlling
Congress in the White House we made
Tripadvisor stop advertising on the
laura ingram show liberals control the
culture yes but right now wouldn't you
rather control the border during during
the Obama years Republicans converted
over a thousand seats at state and local
levels while we were putting vaginas in
formal email movies they were putting
dicks and state houses
the Republicans put nine new senators in
office in 2014 that was their victory we
took al franken out they succeed in
suppressing the minority vote in 34
states meryl streep got off an epic burn
at the golden globes our current and
possibly permanent president can appoint
scott baio to the next Supreme Court
vacancy he can pardoned himself and I
wouldn't put it past him to try and
cancel the next election but if he does
oh he's gonna see a lot of this